[Music]
another animal cruelty case
rocks the las vegas valley a dog was
found mutilated
murdered and left on the side of the
road in a cage and it's just the latest
of many we've seen this summer
sasha loftus spoke to the woman who made
this horrible discovery and she joins us
now live with the latest sasha
denise this is a story that no one
really wants to hear the woman i spoke
with who discovered this dog says
the image keeps her up at night she says
she doesn't want this to happen
ever again it was just really a terrible
scene for anyone to have to come upon
lisa jagazinski describes the moment she
made
this horrific discovery who could
possibly
ever harm a dog like this a dog abused
killed and left in a metal crate on the
side of this road
in the northwest valley it's an image
that i'll never get out of my head
this cruelty case follows a disturbing
trend we're seeing here in the valley a
dog found with severe chemical burns
another dog hung from a fence and
several animals
left in hot cars and garages animal
neglect animal abuse it is a criminal
action chelsea ward of southern nevada
animal rescue league tells me she's seen
a spike in neglect and abuse cases
as more people surrender their pets
filling shelters and rescues
it's coming more to light and like more
to public view because people are
getting sloppy
people are they're just not being
patient ward also says
it's crucial to report any abuse you see
the more people that speak up when they
suspect something or see something
the higher the chance of something
getting caught before it's too late
and as for lisa she encourages anyone
adopting a dog to consider
the commitment and take this kind of
violence
seriously if somebody could harm a dog
like that
what would they do to a human
the metro police says this is an ongoing
investigation if you have any
information you
are asked to contact them the department
also has
two full-time detectives dedicated to
animal cruelty cases like this
reporting live in the newsroom tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now